[Música]
este gran jardín se encuentra en un
lugar poco usual es resulta difícil de
creer que estas frutas y verduras
crezcan en el desierto
estas son a almendras
son importantes porque atraen a los
pájaros y a las abejas
hace 15 años no había nada más que arena
aquí todo ha germinado gracias a la
voluntad de este hombre durante mi viaje
es autodidacta y pionero de la
agricultura sostenible en áfrica
si estaba desierto había ni un solo
árbol aquí todo estaba seco incluso era
un campo de fútbol para los niños del
pueblo
después de haber encontrado agua a 4
metros bajo tierra goran en viaje compro
esta tierra por muy poco dinero y
comenzó a darle vida de nuevo
no había nada aquí así que lo primero
fue recuperar la fertilidad del suelo
crear la primera capa de vegetación con
los árboles
goran en viaje plantó su primer
cocoteros y luego otras docenas bajo la
mirada incrédula de los campesinos de la
región
sabía que pensaban que estaba loco luego
vieron que este desierto abandonado que
estas tierras abandonadas son una de las
mejores una de las más productivas de la
zona entonces me dijeron que había algo
que era un milagro no hay ningún milagro
simplemente quisimos cambiar y creemos
en ello
goran ndiaye es la primera persona en
senegal en adoptar la permacultura este
concepto permite crear una multitud de
pequeños ecosistemas donde por ejemplo
los árboles fomentan el crecimiento de
otros cultivos de plantas al retener la
humedad
yahvé de debajo de los papas o cultiven
nabos que ya fueron cosechados y
vendidos savia lechuga aquí cultivamos
cebollas debajo de los papas así que
había cultivos de múltiples niveles
todo esto sin ningún tipo de químicos la
otra ventaja es que se pueden tener
cosechas durante todo el año lo que
permite garantizar que los agricultores
tengan un ingreso regular los
estudiantes de goran en viaje han
aprendido de sus enseñanzas
esta es la menta que creció protegida
por el cocotero que le proporciona un
microclima favorable
creo que funciona perfectamente
a través de su experiencia acuerdan en
viaje pretende luchar contra los
cultivos tradicionales de senegal piensa
que los monocultivos de maní arroz o
mijo hacen que los agricultores se
queden en la pobreza y son responsables
de la desertificación debido a la tala
de árboles y para luchar por esta causa
fueron en viaje también transformó su
granja en una escuela
gracias a dios tengo un reemplazo que
puede hacer bien el trabajo
ese es mi equipo de combate hacemos un
equipo cada año unos 20 agricultores
reciben formación en agricultura
sostenible
vamos a visitar a mohamed van de cavar a
un ex alumno de la escuela de caída hoy
en su propia granja
no tenía un campo después de mi
formación caída me ayudó dándome esto
así que depende de mí mostrar que se
puede vivir con una hectárea dignamente
al igual que el otras cinco personas
recibieron una parcela de una hectárea
de tierra después de su formación para
poder empezar esto está bien
antes de regresar a senegal y continuar
con su entrenamiento
mohamed trato de llegar a europa
ilegalmente durante años no tuvo éxito
tres años más tarde el joven agricultor
puede cosechar sus vegetales y continuar
mejorando su granja
actualmente vivo con lo que me da mi
granja hallado a mi madre con lo que
gano aquí mi vida cambió desde que volví
a caída
unos 40 ex alumnos de goran en viaje se
han establecido en diferentes regiones
del país demostrando que otra forma de
agricultura una que respete la tierra y
el medio ambiente es posible en senegal